clap de fin pour le festival du film
documentaire l'événement qui se
déroulait du 17 au 20 novembre à saint
quentin en yvelines a permis aux saint
quentinois de découvrir des films sur
teddy riner david douillet ou encore le
prof de gym de benoît grimont faisons un
point sur ce festival
pendant trois jours le festival saint
quentin à diffuser pas moins d'une
trentaine de documentaires un bilan
positif salué lors de la cérémonie de
clôture
les films ont exploré le sport sous tous
ses aspects le dépassement de soi
l'émotion l'argent une plongée dans un
univers situationnelle il ya assez peu
de documentaires toute façon cinéma qui
sortent au cinéma sur le sport drôle
alors c'était une bonne sélection de
qualité le prix des cinémas a été remis
au réalisateur benoît grimont pour son
film le prof de gym dans un collège
parisien sensible l'histoire d'un prof
de ps qui enseigne à ses élèves médusé
la danse contemporaine
pendant le cours de gym le prof au lieu
de faire du foot du badminton je ne sais
quoi ils essayent et il essaye de
transmettre et il enseigne la danse
contemporaine ont fait la même chose on
fait le même exercice c'est la même idée
sauf que c'est plus des mots des petits
mouvements
et donc c'est pareil il est connecté ça
nécessite la même concentration on voit
la transition et la transformation ces
gamins qui au début on n'avait rien à
faire et qui se retrouvent avec un petit
quelque chose dans le coeur une belle
leçon d'humilité donc qui ne manquera
pas de susciter des vocations
en attendant rendez vous est donné l'an
prochain pour une nouvelle édition du
festival saint quentin